let's talk about the next steps
politically after Senate Senator
McCain's death correspondent Peter Doocy
is in Arizona tonight reading Peter good
evening Bret there has been a ton of
talk about Cindy McCain possibly being
appointed to succeed her husband in the
Senate and today a spokesman for the
family deflected questions about whether
or not she wants the job but did say
that the late Senator McCain favored a
different demographic I think a Hispanic
woman probably would have been his pick
for a successor if he did live long
enough to you know had had the
opportunity Arizona's governor Doug
Ducey says he's going to wait and tell
after McCain's funeral to name a
successor though Brett what about
there's also obviously a primary
tomorrow to replace retiring Senator
Jeff Flake yes and the candidate whose
poll numbers were once so high that they
were seen as part of the reason that
flake decided to retire dr. Kelly Ward
is taking heat tonight because she wrote
on Facebook or she was believed to
suggest on Facebook that the
announcement about McCain's cancer
treatment ending was timed to hurt her
campaign she says now she sees how that
message could be misunderstood but
denies the sentiment I was saying that
there is a concerted effort out there to
turn everything that we do back to the
negative and if you look at look at the
press and you look at the social media
over really the last three years since I
started running against Senator McCain
and I ran against Senator McCain not
because I dislike him as a person but
because I dislike his policies I dislike
his votes the front-runner now in this
race congresswoman martha mcsalley is
confidently looking past the primary and
two of the Democrat running unopposed
congresswoman Kyrsten Sinema
I know the price of freedom while we
were in harm's way in uniform Kyrsten
Sinema was protesting us in a pink tutu
and denigrating our service
President Trump has not made an
endorsement in this race but he has
pardoned one of the candidates for
criminal contempt Sheriff Joe Arpaio who
insists he'd be the most different than
retiring senator flake I'm not going to
go in front of the Senate and Stour
bad-mouthing our commander-in-chief or
criticizing him for everything he does
that's not gonna happen with me I got a
problem the president will go in the
back door talk about it you turn on the
local news here in Arizona almost no
talk about the primary it has been
completely eclipsed by coverage
celebrating John McCain's life but the
lack of attention might not make much of
a difference because the Secretary of
State's office tells us that a majority
of ballots have already been mailed in
right Peter Doocy live in Tempe Arizona
Peter thanks